what are all 12 mythical Zone fruits who
is the strongest mythical Zone user how
would the mythical Zone users from Bonus
materials like the overpowered vampire
fruit user match up to the strongest
main story mythical Zone users we'll be
answering all of these questions as we
explain and rank all 12 mythical Zone
users from weakest to strongest
including the little known non-canon
ones that are very interesting so make
sure to stay tuned for that now channel
parking within and smash that like
button if you enjoy seeing one piece
videos like this one if you haven't
already join the not come up by
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to try all
notifications and without further Ado
let's jump into It spoilers and all
coming in at number 12 we turn to a
video game specifically to one Piece
unlimited World red in this video game
we find out about Inu Inu no me model
baked anuki literally translated to dog
dog fruit model monster raccoon dog it
allows its user to transform into a
Tanuki monster and it was eaten by get
this a pen Oda designed the mythical
Zone pen called Pato and Pato belongs to
Patrick Redfield who is a hype figure
that we'll discuss later on the list
because he's obviously way stronger Pato
may not be the most overpowered mythical
Zone user but he's definitely
interesting he can use the tip of his
tail to write and furthermore has the
ability to transform leaves into objects
and people by writing on them his owner
uses this ability to create clones to
fight for him but the cute Pato himself
has improved himself to be much of a
fighter so I wouldn't feel Justified
putting him any higher on this list and
now it's time to shout out to sponsor of
today's video War Thunder if you're like
me you're very interested in military
history and Anime but it's not often you
can combine these two passions while
thankfully War Thunder has you covered
experience some amazing military action
in this game while also enjoying the oh
so important anime Vibes use your
favorite anime theme skins and decals
for your tanks aircraft and ships War
Thunder contains hard-pounding combat
combined with epic customization so
you'll never want to say goodbye to this
waifu filled Battlefield picture
yourself piloting your dream fighter jet
covered in anime girls lying high in the
sky and raining destruction down on your
enemies like a true pirate king or
rolling through Enemy Lines in a tank
that rocks your waifu's beautiful face
watch your enemies bow before your power
and your waifu plus they've got awesome
waifu dakimakuras so you have your
number one anime girl there with you
while you crush your enemies can
anything sound sweeter
[Music]
so what are you waiting for download War
Thunder for free right now from the link
in the description and get a dakimakura
pillow and other bonuses coming in at
number 11 we fittingly got stronger who
has the uma uma no me model Pegasus or
the horse horse fruit model Pegasus and
he has seen his fair share of battles
stronger is Doc Hugh's pet and as you
can see a lot of the lower entries of
this list will belong to pets rather
than later on in the list where we get
to the main Fighters like his owner
stronger is very sick most of the time
but yet these two are still strong
enough to have privileged positions on
Blackbeard's crew which is impressive in
and of itself although how sickly these
two are is an ongoing joke it's notable
that stronger survived Magellan's deadly
venom and a Shockwave attack from Golden
Buddha sengoku who will also get to
later on in this list as a horse who ate
the Pegasus fruit as you may imagine one
of the big benefits is that he got wings
now and can fly while carrying doc q and
even Blackbeard at the same time but we
haven't seen enough yet to put this
sickly horse any higher on the list
we'll see if other cool Powers besides
flight get revealed down the line number
10 we have the non-canon toritori no me
model nue aka the bird bird fruit model
knew it this fruit was featured in The
One Piece art nue a series of artwork
created for the one piece X Kyoto event
in 2017 that depicts a non-canon story
of the straw hats in wano the fruit was
eaten by toratsugu a resident abuano
which is fitting because the nue is a
mythical Japanese Yokai it's a chimera
Beast that borrows different body parts
from different animals for instance it
has the Facebook monkey the body of a
tiger the Mane of a lion and a snake for
a tail when toratsugu transforms into
the Yokai he has the ability to fly but
is nevertheless overpowered relatively
quickly and easily by Luffy who knocks
him out with a single punch Oda himself
drew the climactic scene where Luffy
battles the new way this user is similar
to stronger in the says that he gained
flight from his fruit which seems to be
the main benefit but the fact that he's
a chimera Beast served however shortly
as an antagonist for Luffy is not a pet
and is not as sickly makes me put him
above stronger for now number nine we
have the use of the hitohito no me model
onudo AKA human human fruit mythical
model onudo onyudo translates to Big
Monk and is a reference to a large monk
Yokai in Japanese folklore the current
user is onimaru a fox that used to be
friends with Master swordsman shimotsuki
ushimaru the Zorro look like which makes
sense since we recently figured out that
he is the great uncle of Zorro like with
chopper the fruit has given onimaru an
animal the ability to turn into a human
more or less and in his giant monk form
where he Towers over Zorro he can speak
as well in his humanoid form he's called
yukimaru as you'd expect onimaru's
mythical Zone comes with increased
endurance letting him make it through a
lot including arrows and even a bazooka
I sort of want to just say that all
mythical Zone users have mythical
endurance since it seems like so many of
them them can bounce back from so much
although more so now that a certain plot
armored main character was revealed to
B1 as well for onimaru it makes sense
that his giant size comes with increased
power as well it's also noteworthy that
yukimaru exchanged blows with Zorro in
his Yokai form he's obviously not
stronger than Zorro but still you need
to be pretty skilled to not get
overwhelmed immediately by our Zoro so
all in all pretty impressive stuff for a
fox and I'll just say that onimoto to me
feels like a really cool throwback to
Chow Chow the dog from Orange town
obviously Oda gave the fox more
development in a mythical Zone fruit but
they have similar energies for sure they
just happen to be protective over
different things number eight we got the
corrupted Shogun of wano kurosumi Orochi
in his heavy heavy no me model yamata
noorochi now he's not someone with
associate with extraordinary fighting
prowess but he has so many lives it's
almost impossible to kill the dude this
fruit might remind you of Naruto
specifically of Orochimaru its English
name is the snake snake fruit model
yamata no Orochi and it's based on an
eight-headed serpent slash dragon in
Japanese mythology this fruit lets
Orochi transform into a giant
eight-headed serpent we've seen that
Orochi can easily grab and trap a person
within the jaws of one of his serpent
heads Having Eight heads also lets you
attack multiple people at once which is
useful the fruit as many of us predicted
also lets you survive being beheaded one
mythical parallel of the yamatano Orochi
is the Hydra and Hercules and most of us
may remember that cutting off one of its
heads never did a trick in fact in that
example multiple heads would grow back
to replace the first at one point
kaidobi heads Orochi which wasn't that
surprising after all why would such a
strong figure want to keep someone as
annoying cowardly and proud as Orochi
around longer than necessary later
Orochi recovered somehow and then ran
into the red scabbards fukurokudu
informed him that the red scabbards
didn't even know that he'd already died
once at kaido's hand what might have
been a crazy reveal to them ended up
being an anticlimactic but hilarious
Revenge after Orochi transformed into
his eight-headed form and arrogantly
talked about how he would finish off the
injured red scabbards the scabbards went
on to slice off all of his heads
effortlessly commenting on how they have
no time to waste on the likes of Orochi
now this is as far as we got when I
dropped my first mythical zones
explained video at that point we weren't
sure if oroshi would survive having all
of his heads taken off but I mentioned
it wouldn't be surprising if he did
considering his mythical Zone fruit and
as if to not disrespect a mythical Zone
Oda did in fact have Orochi survive even
those multibeheadings it seems that
kandro's flame finally took him out and
for him to finally die he or he had to
neutralize his mythical Zone power with
the help of C prism stone nails so to
take him out they had to temporarily
make him in effect a non-fruit user
which still Hypes up how powerful his
fruit actually was in the end the
yamatano rochi is a very interesting
fruit with unique abilities like most
mythical Zone fruits I honestly don't
even know why but if anything would have
killed him if he Ori didn't neutralize
his fruit Powers but cool fruits don't
always go to cool or even especially
strong characters and this is one of
those times although I found a fruit
fascinating Orochi himself was
definitely not worthy of such a mythical
fruit number seven is one of the
Blackbeard's ten Titanic commanders
Crescent Moon Hunter Katarina Devon she
ate the Inu Inu no me model QB nokitsune
for Pokemon and Naruto fans is pretty
much like the nine-tailed fox fruit and
in the VIS manga is called the dog dog
fruit mythical type model nine-tailed
fox Devon is 36 years old after the time
Skip and her current Bounty is unknown
but we do know that she's a whopping 11
feet and 10 inches tall or 361
centimeters she can use her fruit to
transform into a nine-tailed fox and
perhaps more interestingly she can use
the power to transform herself into
anyone and impersonate them during
chapter 925 we saw the fruit in action
when she used it against Gekko Moria
tricking the latter into thinking that
Absalom was still alive she does
transform back after it's revealed that
Absalom is dead and that she had used
stole his clear clear fruit it's the
best fruit for disguising yourself as
someone else because it allows the user
to transform their clothes as well
unlike the clunk clone fruit I wouldn't
be surprised if life with kaido's fruit
which we'll get to in a bit more
different fruit-related powers reveal
themselves as the story progresses for
Devon since the cool thing about
mythical zones is they usually come with
multiple abilities not just one however
for now we haven't seen much of this
fruit unlike Orochi though Devon was
known for her strength even without her
mythical fruit ivanko said her name
first when she was talking about how
only the worst prisoners go to level 6
of impel down then there's the fact that
she was one of the strongest of the
level 6 prisoners and survived
blackbeards free for all level 6 battle
then Blackbeard even chose her to be one
of the 10 Titanic commanders so for all
these reasons it's not hard for me to
put Devin higher than Orochi on this
list number six is Yamato kaido's child
and number one Odin fan as we found out
Yamato also has a mythical Zone through
daily the inonomi model okuchi no makami
or the dog dog fruit model
okuchinomakami we're told that it is a
rare mythical wolf and that it is a
guardian Spirit of wano and that made it
all the more painful for kaido that
Yamato was using it and claiming to be
Odin at first it seemed like she might
have eaten it by accident but now with
the Revelation that specifically Zone
fruits have a will of their own in
chapter 1044. it's possible that the
fruit in a sense chose Yamato because
her beliefs complemented that of a wano
protector so well the fruit lets Yamato
turn into a wolf God pretty much and
we've seen the cool looking hybrid form
clash with kaido's own hybrid form not
only is it clearly mythical and Powerful
it's also very valuable because of its
symbolic value for wano specifically it
would obviously be easier to rule a
country if their Guardian deity was
supporting you rather than challenging
your Authority another hype fact is that
kaido says he worked hard to acquire
that devil fruit and whenever Yanko
worked hard to acquire a specific fruit
like BlackBerry here with the dark dark
fruit and even Shanks with the gumugumo
know me it's always a sign that the
fruit isn't especially big deal keep in
mind this is not just a mythical Zone
but a carnivorous mythical Zone making
the fruit especially well suited for
combat and it would have to be special
to allow one to repeatedly clash with
the so-called world's strongest creature
in his overpowered hybrid form we saw
how quickly kaido took out Luffy the
first time they fought so the fact that
Yamato can occupy the former yonko for
so long while he's in his strongest form
is no small feat we've also seen Yamato
fire a mouth blast called the Muji
Glacier Fang at kaido that was met with
one of his own blast breaths and the
attacks canceled each other out it's an
interesting attack name that lands a
fire versus ice Dynamic to the kaido vs
Yamato fight more recently Yamato saved
the day by encasing the majority of
kaido's bombs in ice and thus prevented
kanjuro's fire from setting off a giant
all-encompassing explosion Yamato and
the mythical wolf God fruit did not
disappoint and as I've said many times I
would have loved to have a mythical Zone
user like Yamato joined the straw hat
crew but since we relatively recently
found out that we already have one as
we'll get into later I'm not as bothered
about her not joining the crew I always
said it wouldn't make much sense
symbolically for the guardian deity of
wano to leave the island especially if
the will of Zone fruits will continue to
be an important factor in the story it
was always likely that this mythical
Zone would push Yamato towards staying
near wano so Yamato can watch over and
protect it if the need arises but as far
as the ranking goes I don't think I need
to spend too much time explaining why
someone's so strong and who did so well
against kaido is being placed above the
other characters on this list Devin
definitely seems to have more upper
sleeves but can't put her above Yamato
from what we've seen and even taking
into account that there's more to the
Crescent Moon Hunter than we've seen so
far it's still hard to picture her being
stronger than Yamato right now for
number five let's look at a character
who is definitely worthy of his mythical
Zone fruit Dr Marco the Phoenix Marco is
as legendary as Yahoo commanders come he
was the right-hand man to Whitebeard the
man called the strongest in the world
and the closest to one piece he is
currently 45 years old and he's
October's very own like me so I'm glad
to see him in the top five he's six feet
eight inches tall and his Bounty is
1.374 billion berries a bounty bigger
than Queen's former impressive Bounty of
1.32 billion so even among yako
commanders his Bounty is top tier
although it was revealed that King
actually had a higher former Bounty at
1.39 billion side note how crazy is it
that injured Zorro beat a dude with a
higher Bounty than Marco absolutely
insane to think about how far our crew
has come but before Zorro did that Marco
was albeit temporarily handling king and
queen at the same time he even appeared
to have the upper hand although he did
admit that not surprisingly it's quite
hard to stall two with bounties over a
billion of course Marco the Phoenix has
the Phoenix fruit more specifically the
toritori Nomi model Phoenix or the bird
bird fruit model Phoenix another way to
trans related is Immortal bird another
hype detail about the mythical fruit
back in chapter 553 we first saw Marco
use his ability and it was to deflect an
admiral's attack no less without
breaking a sweat Marco's fruit allows
him to adopt the properties of a phoenix
or to straight up fully transform into a
blue phoenix Marco's blue flames allow
him to heal himself or others this is
one of the reasons that the immortal
bird translation is so apt because Marco
can seemingly heal from otherwise lethal
wounds using blue flames it's like an
enhanced logia because Marco can take
hits as if they just went through him
but in his case he could also use the
blue flames to heal from hockey infused
attacks as well as mentioned Marco could
block Admiral kizeru's attack and he
also successfully blocked Admiral
akainus as well during the Paramount war
and he would later have no lasting
damage showing just how Superior this
fruit is to Ace's flame flame fruit
which was easily defeated by Akainu as
mentioned earlier he was able to use his
fruit for a while to also hold his own
while fighting against king and queen at
the same time two yako commanders with
both confirmed bounties over a billion
berries obviously this doesn't mean he
could actually beat them both at the
same time and pero Sparrow pointed out
that he looked exhausted but it's still
very impressive considering how good of
a fighter Marco is in battle it's all
the more impressive that he can be just
as helpful when it comes to Healing
others he has used his Flames to help
heal others and more specifically he's
used them as a way to help prevent the
further spread of Queen's virus in many
people notably Marco's Flames won't burn
you as they burn like conventional
Flames but they can definitely be used
to reinforce the power of His attacks so
the op power comes with both offensive
defensive and healing capabilities
notably Oda has told us that Marco's
healing has limitations in a question
corner so he's not necessarily Immortal
in his Phoenix form it's quite likely
that if Marco drains all of his stamina
he won't be able to use his healing
powers which might explain why he
sometimes leaves minor wounds like
scratches or bruises unhealed in battle
another way that Marco could definitely
be killed is if you expose him to Sea
Stone then he won't be able to use his
regeneration on Mortal wounds it should
be said that Marco's forces fought
against Blackbeard's forces in the
payback War about a year after the
Paramount war and Marco's side was
obliterated even so Marco made it out
fine without suffering lasting wounds
thanks to his Phoenix Powers but I think
that's enough about Marco for the
purposes of this video his mythical
fruit is one of my favorites and though
it has limits the fruit along with
Marco's own prowess has let him at the
very least exchange blows with many of
the best fighters in the world without
taking any lasting damage number four is
the user of the battlebato no me model
vampire aka the bad bad fruit model
vampire he is the owner of the already
mentioned pet pen Pato and also from the
same non-canon video game so don't take
this one too seriously either this fruit
gives its user Patrick Redfield the
ability to turn into a you guessed it
vampire this character was designed by
Oda himself and serves as the main
antagonist of the one Piece unlimited
World Red game again this is non-canon
but according to sengoku Redfield was
powerful enough to rival the pirate king
in his prime and Whitebeard and this was
before he ate his devil fruit with his
unique new mythical Zone Powers he can
sharpen his teeth and use them too you
guessed that pretty much suck the blood
of his enemies the age quickly as a
result while he becomes stronger and
through these means he gains access to
Eternal youth now in theory this sounds
very overpowered and someone with the
power to rival Prime Goldy Roger and
Whitebeard plus the power of Eternal
youth to stay in their own Prime in
addition to cool vampire powers could
even be at the top of this list but the
non-canon story confuses things and
makes me not put him on the top at one
point Redfield has his youth again and
has taken Luffy's and Luffy still
manages to knock him down and then
thanks to Luffy's motivational speech
Redfield decides that he won't use his
powers to stay young and at his prime
but will try to be the pirate king as an
old man then he fails to beat the straw
hats in a fight and again this is not
Luffy the strongest this is not the gear
5 Luffy we know today but a much weaker
one in this video game so with all of
this stuff in mind I just couldn't put
Redfield higher than this on the list
number three is sengoku the former Fleet
Admiral and living legend he was one of
the major figures back during Goldie
Rogers time along with Whitebeard Shiki
and GARP after the time skip this dude
is 79 years old he has an especially
interesting mythical Zone fruit namely
the hitohito Nomi model daibutsu or the
human human fruit model Buddha he has
the ability to transform into a giant
gold Buddha during chapter 578 at Marine
Ford we see his giant form launch shock
waves at Blackbeard Blackbeard and his
crew are shown to be rattled by the
attack wedded out eyes blood and all
that jazz but obviously the attack
doesn't keep Blackbeard down obviously
his size and physical power in this form
are great and although he failed to
execute Ace with a punch thanks to
Luffy's inflated stomach and a candle
wall his power still led to the
execution platform collapsing so that's
sengoku we haven't seen much of his
power in action but what we have seen
was no doubt epic definitely a power fit
for a former Fleet Admiral he's passed
his prime to be sure but I can't picture
this Legend doing worse than Redfield
did in that fight with that version of
Luffy from the unlimited World Red game
so as not to disrespect the golden Fleet
Admiral I gotta Place him here number
two is kaido the leader of the Beast
Pirates and the man who was called the
strongest creature in the world before
another mythical Zone creature defeated
him as we'll get into soon kaido's
Bounty was over 4.6 billion berries
meaning among the living yonko he had
the highest bounty after white beer
passed on so the question was for a long
time what exact devil fruit did kaido
have what mythical zone is worthy of
going to the leader who stands at the
apex of the animal kingdom that is the
Beast Pirates there were theories that
he had a straightforward dragon fruit
even theories that he was a dragon who
had some kind of human fruit but during
chapter 999 big mom revealed that on the
day rocks fell into ruin at God Valley
she gave kaido a legendary model of the
fish fish fruit and she even says
because of that kaido owes her his life
that's how big of a favor this fruit was
in her view the official name for the
legendary mythical fish fish fruit was
given to us in a data book and it was
the me model said you or the fish fish
fruit model serial the setu is an oswar
dragon and if this at first confuses you
how a fish fish fruit can turn into a
dragon just think of Magikarp and
Gyarados and Pokemon Gyarados 2 is based
off of the Japanese seru which is a turn
based off of a Chinese myth specifically
there's a Chinese Dragon Gate myth where
there's this giant waterfall and if a
carp is able to persevere and make it
all the way to the top of the
practically impossible to climb
waterfall it will become a dragon I'd
like to think personally that kaido's
Dragon form is a sign that he was
skilled enough and worked hard enough to
awaken the fruit and usually the user of
this fruit starts off as a kind of weak
Magikarp rather than as a majestic
Dragon this isn't confirmed though and
if it does start out as a Magikarp fruit
then the question arises can it allow
its user to actually swim or at least
breathe underwater despite the usual
devil fruit curse but that's a topic for
another video and back to the question
if this is a fitting food for the
world's strongest creature it definitely
seems to be since Eastern dragons like
this one were often considered to be
extremely powerful and were even
worshiped as Gods it's almost like we
need another Godly fruit to take down
such a powerful fruit user but back to
kaido's specific Powers we often see him
transform into his Oswald Dragon form
and more recently in the story we even
got to see his hybrid form which is
accompanied by a very cool tale overall
I really like the aesthetic of his
hybrid form kaido's Dragon form is the
biggest Zone transformation we've seen
and he absolutely dominates the skyline
when he's flying overhead his Dragon
form is so big and powerful that it
stated he could obliterate all of kuri
if he thrashes about in a drunken stupor
while in his Dragon form that's without
even trying to he could destroy an
entire region of a country the insane
durability of his mythical scales has
also been noted multiple times during
chapter 923 Luffy hit kaido many times
with hockey enhanced attacks and
although they land it and looked painful
kaido got up unscathed like absolutely
nothing happened and went on to take out
Luffy with one blow it's also been said
about kaido's fruit that it gives kaido
access to more supernatural abilities
than any other mythical Zone we've seen
so far although I feel like the mythical
Zone that took him down will definitely
give it a run for its money one such
ability is that you can create flame
clouds that for all intents and purposes
allow him to fly and can even lift up an
entire Island and turn it into a flying
Castle additionally kaido has been seen
launching devastating fire blast from
his mouth in Dragon mode and hybrid mode
and the list goes on this truly Godlike
creature has turned his Roar into
lightning he has released Blades of wind
strong enough to cut off a red
scabbard's arm and he's able to summon
multiple tornadoes which led to zero
labeling him a natural disaster it seems
like in close combat for the most part
kaido's hybrid form is the most powerful
since he saves that one for last he's
not unheardable because attacks that can
bypass his tough scales can cause harm
like Advanced hockey infused attacks the
open no me surgical techniques and so on
apps after all Odin did succeed in
leaving a huge lasting scar on him still
there's no doubt that this was one of
the best devil fruits of all it even
makes the sea a usual devil fruit
weakness a non-issue because the dragon
form can just fly over it not to mention
the possibility that even if rendered
paralyzed a fish fish fruit could
potentially let the user breathe
underwater or at least I'm gonna believe
that until Oda tells me otherwise the
final overpowered form kaido used in his
fight against Luffy was Cayenne daiko
AKA fire dragon great torch kaido's
giant dragon body is surrounded by
flames in this form this means that
almost nobody could even touch him let
alone hit him because the heat of the
form melts when it comes into contact
with the only reason Luffy could touch
let alone defeat kaido is because he
mastered Advanced hockey that allows him
to hit his opponent without making
direct physical contact very few people
have this level of hockey Mastery and so
kaido would for most people be truly
Untouchable but luckily Luffy the next
mythical Zone user we're talking about
is one of the elite few who could defeat
this version of kaido and of course for
number one we got the mythical Zone user
on the straw hat crew Luffy our
protagonist himself long story short if
you haven't got the memo yet the
gomugomunomi is actually not a paramecia
rubber fruit but a mythical Zone fruit
its actual name is the human human fruit
mythical model Nika and Nika was a sun
god associated with Liberation so it
makes sense that when Luffy awakens this
fruit his hair looks like it's made out
of flames and turns white Luffy calls
this awakened form gear five and I gotta
say it reminded me of the Super Saiyan
form nothing wrong with that it's not a
bad thing for it to be a nod to the
Super Saiyan form in fact it's a nice
homage to the very important Dragon Ball
series that paved the way for many
Shonen like one piece but don't get me
wrong either this is a unique form with
very unique powers as we're about to get
into obviously Luffy's fruit deserves
its own dedicated video and accordingly
we published one called all five gears
explore Lane but for this video I'll
summarize the gist of it it's like the
most special fruit as far as we know
it's the only one that was so dangerous
and special that the government changed
its name It's associated with the sun
god Nika with joy boy and now with our
main character and the last time it
awakened was more than 800 years ago so
since then the users before Luffy only
got to the rubber stage of it that's a
nice little aspect to it because yeah
Luffy still has a super special fruit
but at least he had to work hard in
order to unlock its specialness many
others probably had this Godly fruit and
never got to this point the five Elders
further explained that they attempted to
get the sun god fruit for 800 years and
not once did they succeed it actively
tried to escape their grasp and as I
already explained that type of
personification makes sense because
specifically Zone fruits are said to
contain a will of their own this
suggests that the fruit probably picked
Luffy similarly to how I believe
Yamato's fruit probably picked her it
wasn't just Luffy happening to eat it it
probably called out the Hem on some
level so what are some of the properties
of this God fruit we know the rubber
part but it's explained that after
Awakening the rubbery body of the user
gains greater physical strength and
freedom it is said by the five Elders
that there is no power more ridiculous
with two exclamation marks in the
official translation it's portrayed as
the biggest deal and for good reason
it's also mentioned that the rubber body
lets the user fight in whatever way he
fancies bringing smiles to the faces of
the people another name for the Sun God
we're told is also the warrior of
Liberation now that's a big deal the
quote saying that a user of the fruit
can fight in whatever way they fancy it
seems to imply that Luffy is only
limited by his imagination when it comes
to the way in which he fights and the
powers which he manifests I won't go so
far as to say that he can do anything
yet because some of this might be more
Legend than truth but it'll be
interesting to see how accurate the
description is as the story progresses
and Luffy continues to use his new
awakened Powers so far we've seen Luffy
use his awakened fruit to grab kaido's
Dragon form like he was on a mere Snake
toy and pull him up to the roof he
proceeded to practically enter a tune
world he spun kaido around and slammed
him into the ground over and over again
kaido's eyes popped out like in Looney
Tunes suggesting that Luffy can make his
opponents take on these exaggerated
characteristics not just himself we also
see Luffy pull a Popeye and summon
massive muscles all of a sudden I mean
if he is strong enough to lift kaido
like this I doubt there's any opponent
he can't lift he also rubberized the
ground and lifted it up to deflect the
blast breath showing his awakened powers
can definitely affect his surroundings
he grabbed and threw lightning like Zeus
he created a Beyond giant fist that was
able to knock out and defeat kaido's
giant flame dragon form but the fruit as
impressive as it is is not why Luffy is
first on this list if Luffy did not have
advanced Mastery over hockey he would
have been melted by kaido's flame dragon
form as kaido himself pointed out haki
is even more important than devil fruits
when looking at a character's strength
and the great pirate king Goldie Roger
became the pirate king without any fruit
so although Luffy defeated the former
strongest creature in the world and in
my opinion deserves to be at the top of
this mythical Zone user list it doesn't
mean he's the strongest character yet he
has awakened an amazing fruit perhaps
the most amazing fruit but still has a
ways to go before he can rule over the
rest as the pirate king the strongest of
all and we'll see perhaps more mythical
Zone users will be revealed who are even
stronger than Luffy is now and this list
may have to be revised but for now I
feel comfortable putting Luffy at the
top as the strongest known mythical Zone
user thanks again to the sponsor of
today's video War Thunder don't forget
to download War Thunder for free from
the link in the description now and get
adaki makura pillow and other bonuses
even though mythical Zone users tend to
be strong Yanko tend to be even stronger
so if you like exploring strong
characters like these ones you don't
want to miss my all seven yako and their
powers explained video link on screen
right now and I'll see you there